something about practice man when you
come into the arena and you see me play
you see me play don't you you see me
give everything I got right what we're
talking about practice right now we're
talking about practice man I look I hear
you I it's funny to me too and I mean
it's strange it's strange to me too but
we're talking about practice man we're
not even talking about the game the
actual game when it matters we're
talking about practice that's it and
joining us right now here 18 years later
on the Rich Eisen show is the Hall of
Fame coach of those 76ers he is Larry
Brown how are you Larry um well I miss
my family I feel bad for everybody that
has to go through this and hopefully
things will change for the better but
you know it's amazing on on this state
so many times people are interested in
here and my take on what just transpired
but you know it's it'll be fun to talk
about it okay and let's let's get into
it
Larry what do you think of when you hear
this I mean I just played it in all of
its 22 mentions of practice glory that's
the that's it from beginning to end
there's no edits in there I'm wondering
your thoughts when you hear it back from
beginning to end well one I feel bad
because I wasn't aware you know of his
loss you know I know how loyal Allen is
and how loyal he was tall his friends
you know growing up you know in Hampton
Virginia he his mom was young when he
had them and Allen's
friends were so close to him matter of
fact you know when he went and signed
with Shelley a lot of the guys came and
lived with Allen but I
I heard two different sides about how
the thing actually happened I heard
Billie Kings account and that coach's
account the way I remember we ended up
losing to Boston which you know
obviously was difficult but usually
after the season ends you always have
they call him an extra meeting where you
meet with the players and individually
and you talked about things as the coach
I needed to do better and things as a
player that they were planning on doing
the summer to help them improve and
usually it's pretty open and honest
which I loved that part of it if I
remember Allen missed the meeting and
you know you had mentioned it came after
us losing a tough series after we had a
great year the year before but uh Allen
missed the meeting that he was supposed
to have with me and we met I told him we
should meet at 3 o'clock and we met at 3
o'clock and all he wanted to talk to me
about was coach are you going to trade
me and that was really first and
foremost on his mind and I said
basically Allen as great as you are and
you're our best player and probably his
good players we have in our sport that I
said in order for us to take the next
step and continue to get better
you got to set an example and we talked
about things I thought he needed to do
better and things that you know he felt
would help him in terms of him develop
and that I need to do better and you
know I'm a stickler for you know
everybody doing the right thing all the
time and especially if you can coach
your best player and he buys into what
you're doing you become a hell of a
coach sure
and nobody admired Allen any more than I
did or is too
mates you know when you hear the
conversation about every time he stepped
out on the court
you never saw anybody compete any harder
or have more of a will to win than he
did I used to talk to him all the time
you know as great as Michael you know
was and all the great players we had in
our league
I thought Alan had an impact on more
people because more people could
identify with him because of his size
and his courage and the way he played
the game and we used to talk all the
time I thought about how he could help
kids you know by setting a good example
and the same thing about how I thought
he could help our team so basically we
had this long conversation and the only
thing that mattered to him during the
time we were talking about is heard
rumors about you know me possibly being
traded coach and I don't want any part
of that I want to be here I love Philly
I love my teammates so he has three
hours between our conversation and then
the press conference and I don't know
what the hell went on during those three
hours and I can only imagine and then
the only thing on his mind was basically
I'm hoping somebody asks me if I'm gonna
be around Philadelphia and I'm not going
to get traded and I'm sure it came up
during our conversation you know I said
Alan you got to be a little bit more you
know conscious about doing all the right
things when we're at a training camp you
know we might be there for 25 days
nobody worked any harder and nobody
could ever fault Alan for his effort on
the court and how hard he competed and
how much he loved his teammates and he
really respected me in a lot of ways I
you know I could talk to Alan one-on-one
and we could talk about any
if I got on and maybe in front of his
teammates that was kind of difficult
because he has so much pride but he goes
to this press conference and I know he
said 22 times he mentioned the word
press comp you know practice but he was
taken back by that conversation that
question because you know after our
season ended that was one of the issues
I had with the press I said Alan needed
to do certain things better but when
they asked him that question all he
wanted the question to be was am I going
to be back here and I guess with the
situation with his friends passing away
and then all of a sudden us losing the
Boston and then all of a sudden you know
they're asking him about practice when
all he wants to talk about is hey I'm
not going to be traded that I think set
them off Larry Brown here on the Rich
Eisen show so what was your first
conversation with him after the press
conference
like Larry I really I really don't know
about that when I you know I always was
pretty honest with Allen and he was
pretty honest with me you know he's made
me a better person and a better coach
he lives in Charlotte right now and I'm
staying here with my grandkids I can't
get back to New York with my family but
you know we were always open and honest
with each other there was there were
things I think as the coach it's really
important that people know what you
expect from them and you're completely
upfront and and tell her tell them
exactly how you feel so if I felt Allen
wasn't doing anything doing things the
right way I would I would tell him I I
didn't even comment after that press
conference one way or another if I
remember correctly
but I can't tell you how many people to
this day talk to me about that oh yeah I
brought Alan back to speak to some of my
teams and it's it's almost incredible to
hear the respect the young players have
Alan and that was my biggest challenge
with him all the time I always always
felt he could have such an impact on
young people if he just would realize
how much they loved him and the things
he needed to do better and we were open
and honest about it but to remember you
know what I said after that press
conference to him I really believe I
didn't even mention it no kidding
because I would imagine that that would
fracture a relationship I mean the the
the media reaction obviously and the fan
reaction and him basically saying you
know I understand what coach is saying
and he was very respect he did say
nothing but you know nice things about
you even in that very press conference
but you know here you are trying to get
him to to be accountable you know off
the game Night Court and him basically
scoffing at the notion of practice being
important that seems to be something
that would fracture a relationship I
don't I don't think you did everything
that ever happened between me and Alan
you know always made our relationships
better I used to tease them all the time
you know I'd get a call from his his
mentor and I used you know I'm I'm gonna
be a little late today or I might not be
at practice today and I used to tease
out and you know I said how many times
says your as deuce his young son gone to
the hospital because he fell down
unexpectedly I used to I used to count
them all and
be honest with you personally when he
didn't practice I was kind of happy come
on you know and I tell him all the time
you know there was one thing you know
when you're a coach and you coach a
talent like him and you coach somebody
that goes out every single day and every
single possession to try to win the game
that gets hit and banged around and
never complains the only time he ever
complained to me is when I took him out
of that basketball game but my
admiration for him was was unbelievable
my frustration was unbelievable as well
because you know I thought he could have
been the very best forever and I thought
if he would have approached it a little
bit differently then he could have been
even better than he really was and you
know when you're a coach that's
something that eats on you and you know
watching this last dance
yeah where we're hearing about Michael
and how hard he worked and the respect
he had for his teammates and his will to
win those are things you know I believed
Allen really had and then unfortunately
when Kobe passed away you know we hear
people talk about you know how hard Kobe
worked you know no talents a gift from
God characters a choice I used to tell
that to Allen all the time and you know
the harder you work the luckier you get
in anything you do and I used to tell
Alan you know there's so much more you
can give to this game if you just act
responsible and do some of the things
that I I would like you to do it would
help us I think as coaches and players
and it would give us a better chance to
win and your career would be incredible
and when Kobe passed away Allen came out
with a statement that I think puts
things really in perspective he said
when Kobe was getting up at 6:00 in the
morning to work out a lot of times I was
coming in just getting in from the club
and you know that eats at me a little
bit because you know my coach's
responsibility is to get the very best
of the players you coach and in some
ways when I look at Allen's career and
realize I think he only played 12 years
I think of what he could have done if
I'd had done a better job in making him
understand the gift he had and the
responsibility at Ari Brown here on the
Rich Eisen show before I let you go
Larry
are you aware it's the 25th anniversary
of Reggie Miller doing to the Knicks in
Madison Square Garden and Spike Lee what
he did with you on the bench as their
coach are you worth today's a 25th
anniversary of that day yeah I'm aware
you know the thing that I watch anything
with a ball you know any sporting event
right and one of the things happen and
now there's so many old games that are
on TV that I get a chance to watch and I
really loved the game back when Reggie
played and we were playing against the
Knicks you know and Reggie got I think
he scored eight points and eight point
nine seconds
I remember the year before I think we
lost one year Patrick made a shot for us
to lose against Game seven and one year
he missed the shot for us to win and get
to play Orlando you know in the finals
of the conference I'm a basketball nut
you know this is a time I think you know
I'm hearing from so many coaches and so
many people
than watching these old games and I'm
telling him every telling everybody Mike
Matt Michael would average 50 a game the
you know the way the game's called now I
think Alan would average 50 as well and
and to be you know people don't realize
this I coached against Reggie the last
game he ever played when we beat the
Pacers in six games here I was in
Detroit I coach against Michael his last
game that ever played when he was
Washington and he played against Philly
the last game of his career and I
coached against Charles I think his last
game
Charlotte's got hurt I think when he was
playing some Phoenix or euston I'm not
sure I'm having a senior moment nice
even I'm in a great moment you know when
you coach as long as I do and we're
lucky enough to coach all these great
players and be surrounded by
unbelievable coaches there's a lot of
anniversaries I have that I'm part of
and I feel really lucky about that well
we're lucky to have you on this show
today Larry in a couple minutes I have
left have you learned anything from
watching the last dance obviously you're
in North Carolina guy just like Michael
you've been there watching his whole
career coaching against him watching it
up close and personal did you have you
learned anything about watching this
documentary Larry Brown yeah well the
the thing that most makes me most happy
is a lot of these young kids a lot of
people are afraid to coach them rich
mm-hm
and you know with social media a lot of
these young kids having other people
influence them I don't think a lot of
these kids realized the greatness of
Michael and how respected he was and why
he was truly great you know yeah God
gave him a gift of all this athleticism
and talent but his characters the thing
that separated them the will to win how
hard he worked to respect he had for his
teammates the respect he had for his
coach I think those are wonderful things
for kids to think about
and then you know with Kobe's passing
somebody that you know I love to watch
you know I coached in Philly when he's
at Lower Merion you know to hear what
Michael did in terms of help and Kobe
evolved I wish there were more and more
older players that would reach out and
help these young kids because you look
at the league and the games that were
played before that we're watching now
you didn't see any young players playing
you know there are all veterans on the
team now we see all these young kids
that are playing a lot of them don't
turn out as well as people expect and a
lot of people say we were failures you
know the system failed these kids not
anybody else but I get the most out of
watching Michael play and I've already
competed how long the road it was for
him to win a championship and how
difficult it was to accomplish that and
how he approached at that that's
something I think we all can learn from
Larry this is an amazing thank you so
much for the time I do hope that you get
back with your family the whole family
gets to be together and you stay safe
and healthy in this crazy time of Kovan
19 you're a treasure Larry you take care
of yourself and I hope you look for my
call again very shortly I love this chat
I'd love to
thanks so much stay well you too
appreciate you let me talk about this
thank you you got it that's a Larry
Brown how awesome was that we talked
about practice and he said that he kind
of digged it when Allen didn't practice
but it drove him crazy
a life of a coach my gosh hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here